ce budget constitue aussi
la première étape de mise en oeuvre de
la future loi de programmation des
finances publiques qui prévoit dans le
texte proposé par le gouvernement retour
du solde public à moins de virgule 9% du
PIB en 2027 et fixe des orientations
pour l'évolution des crédits du budget
général mais aussi pour ceux des
collectivités territoriales et des
administrations de sécurité sociale
ces deux textes sont soumis alors c'est
un peu l'habitude mais quand même cette
année de manière très forte soumis à de
nombreuses incertitudes liées à
l'évolution de la situation
internationale et à ses effets sur les
coûts de l'énergie et l'inflation mais
aussi à l'évolution du cadre européen
des finances publiques de nouvelles
règles pouvant être établies au cours de
la mise en œuvre de la loi de
programmation
même si vous avez fait précéder ce dépôt
d'une phase de consultation originale
dite les dialogues de Bercy auxquels
certains d'entre nous ont pu participer
nos collègues auront un certain moment
de nombreuses questions à vous poser sur
ces deux textes je vous laisse donc la
parole pour un propos liminaire avant de
venir à mes questions à celle du
rapporteur général et de l'ensemble des
sénateurs membres de la commission des
finances je vous rappelle que cette
audition monsieur les ministres est
retransmise sur le site internet du
Sénat je vais donner la parole tout de
suite à Monsieur Bruno Le Maire
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur général
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs je
suis très heureux de vous retrouver avec
le ministre des comptes publics Gabriel
Attal pour vous présenter ce premier
budget du nouveau quinquennat qui est
aussi je le rappelle le 6e de notre
majorité
l'objectif de ce budget c'est de tenir
l'équilibre entre la protection de nos
compatriotes et de nos entreprises face
à l'inflation et le nécessaire
rétablissement des finances publiques
qui doit nous amener à 3% de déficits
publics en 2027 sous les 3% de déficit
public
tout cela dans une période où comme vous
l'avez rappelé monsieur le Président les
incertitudes n'ont jamais été aussi
grande impact de la guerre en Ukraine
sur les prix de l'énergie difficultés
économiques de nos principaux
partenaires économiques les États-Unis
la Chine avec le covid l'Allemagne et
incertitude politique au sein de la zone
euro avec les dernières échéances qui
viennent de se dérouler
dans ce contexte je tiens à rappeler la
très bonne résistance de l'économie
française
2,7% de croissance prévue pour 2022 là
où les meilleures analystes nous
promettaient pas plus de 2,3% des
créations d'emplois qui restent
dynamiques une consommation des ménages
qui se maintient et un investissement
des entreprises qui restent solides tout
cela nous conduit à maintenir une
prévision de croissance positive à 1%
pour 2023
dans ce contexte la priorité va
évidemment à la lutte contre l'inflation
l'inflation continuera de rester à
niveau élevé dans les mois qui viennent
de l'ordre de 6% avant de revenir autour
de 4% dans le courant de l'année 2023
ces chiffres justifient pleinement la
protection que nous apportons au ménage
la protection que nous voulons apporter
aux entreprises qui sinon commenceraient
à baisser leur production voire à la
délocaliser et la protection que nous
apportons aux collectivités locales
s'agissant des ménages nous avons adopté
une stratégie économique singulière dans
la zone euro qui a consisté à protéger
dès l'automne 2021 contre l'augmentation
des prix de l'énergie nous avons gelé
les prix du gaz plafonner les prix de
l'électricité à 4%, et nous avons donc
contenu l'inflation un niveau qui est le
plus faible de tous les pays la zone
euro
nous allons maintenir ce bouclier tout
en l'adaptant progressivement en faisant
passer des hausses de tarifs de 15% sur
les prix du gaz et les prix de
l'électricité au début de l'année 2023
contre plus de 100%, si nous suivions
les prix du marché et plus de 100% ce
serait évidemment intolérable nous
préférons protéger plutôt que de devoir
corriger comme nos fins le nombre
d'États européens en raison des
difficultés sociales le coût de ce
bouclier de 16 milliards d'euros qui
sont inscrits dans le budget 2023 11
milliards d'euros pour le bouclier gaz 5
milliards d'euros pour le bouclier
électricité je rappelle que c'est un
coup net le coût brut est évidemment
beaucoup plus élevé mais il faut déduire
de ce coup brut les prêts de 20
milliards d'euros que nous rapportent le
prélèvement sur les énergéticiens et sur
la rente énergétique
j'ai eu l'occasion de dire à plusieurs
reprises que nous n'étions pas
favorables à des taxes exceptionnelles
sur les super profits qui en réalité
sont des taxes ordinaires et permanentes
sur tous les profits toutes les
entreprises en revanche nous voulons
récupérer la rente des énergéticiens
c'est ce que nous faisons et c'est ce
que nous permet de financer aujourd'hui
le bouclier énergétique nous protégeons
également nos compatriotes en faisant le
choix du travail qui paye nous avons
décidé de revaloriser le barème de l'IR
du montant de l'inflation 5,4%, ce qui
aboutit un résultat très simple nous
évitons à tous ceux qui sont soumis à
l'impôt sur le revenu de payer plus
d'impôts
même si leur salaire augmente le revenu
disponible après un pot restera le même
c'est bien l'objectif de notre politique
économique préserver le travail
faire en sorte que le travail permet de
vivre dignement et ne pas avoir un impôt
qui augmente de manière asymétrique au
fur et à mesure que vous revenus
augmentent c'est un choix de politique
économique qui me paraît essentiel pour
protéger nos compatriotes qui
travaillent contre l'inflation et en
particulier nos compatriotes des classes
moyennes nous voulons aussi protéger des
entreprises et chacun voit bien sur son
territoire à quel point aujourd'hui
l'arrivée des factures énergétiques sur
le bureau des chefs d'entreprise crée de
la crainte de l'inquiétude et beaucoup
d'interrogations
nous avons donc maintenu un tarif régulé
pour toutes les très petites entreprises
chiffre d'affaires inférieures à moins
de millions d'euros et moins de 10
salariés qui bénéficieront de hausse
contenues à 15% et qui garderont le
tarif régulé pour toutes les autres nous
avons fait des demandes à la Commission
Européenne j'ai eu margadvester
longuement au téléphone la semaine
dernière pour avoir des critères plus
simples et des aides plus massives pour
les entreprises qui sont exposées à la
concurrence internationale et qui ont
des tarifs d'énergie qui flambent plus
simple ça veut dire que le critère de 3%
de consommation énergétique dans le
chiffre d'affaires peut être adapté pour
qu'il ne soit pas calculé sur 2021 mais
bien sur l'année de référence 2022 ou
l'année prochaine 2023 ce que vous avez
beaucoup d'entreprises qui peuvent être
des verreries des tours de séchage de
lait des entreprises du carton des
entreprises de l'imprimerie qui ont une
part de l'énergie dans leur chiffre
d'affaires qui représentait avant la
crise ou 2% elles sont pas éligibles et
à cause de la flambée ces prix
représentent 4,5% et ne comprennent pas
pourquoi ne sont pas éligibles et donc
indispensables de contemporainer ces
aides deuxième chose nous avons dit à
quel point le critère débite d'un
négatif était un critère absurde un
débit d'un négatif sur trois mois c'est
une entreprise industrielle qui est
morte
je connais pas beaucoup d'entreprises
industrielles qui peuvent supporter un
débits négatif sur trois mois donc nous
avons demandé que ce soit ramené à une
baisse de bénéfices sur un mois enfin
j'ai demandé le doublement de ces aides
de 25 à 50 millions d'euros et de 50 à
100 millions d'euros doublé le seuil et
le plafond de ces aides d'État que nous
pourrions apporter aux entreprises de
façon à garantir que aucune entreprise
industrielle de mettre la clé sous la
porte à cause de la flambée des prix de
l'énergie nous avons d'ores et déjà
obtenu je peux vous le dire que la
révision de ce cadre des aides d'État
n'interviennent pas au 1er janvier 2023
ce qui aurait été beaucoup trop tard et
pas du tout raccord avec ce qu'est la
réalité des entreprises en France mais
dès le mois d'octobre de cette année
c'est à dire d'ici quelques jours de
façon à ce que les entreprises puissent
bénéficier de ces aides tout de suite au
moment où elle signe leur contrat avec
leurs fournisseurs d'énergie
enfin nous aidons les collectivités
locales nous intéressent au premier chef
avec un fond de 430 millions d'euros qui
était mis en place avec votre aide et
vos conseils lors du PLF 2022 Gabriel
Attal pourra revenir la dessus
notre objectif est également de
transformer notre économie pour rétablir
nos finances publiques et garantir la
baisse la dette publique au moment où
les taux d'intérêt augmentent et la
réduction du déficit pour revenir sous
les 3% de déficit pour cela nous gardons
la même stratégie qui repose sur une
réduction des dépenses le soutien à la
croissance et les réformes de structure
s'agissant des réductions de dépens je
veux redire que nous sommes sortis du
quoi qu'il en coûte que le quoi qu'il en
coûte était approprié pour lutter contre
les conséquences du covid ou la
récession dépassait des 7%, nous
risquions des vagues de faillite par
dizaines de milliers une explosion du
chômage de quoi qu'il en coûte serait
une faute économique face à l'inflation
et ne ferait qu'alimenter l'inflation
faut donc passer à des dispositifs
ciblés comme nous l'avons fait et mettre
fin à tous les dispositifs de soutien
transversaux qui avaient pu avoir cours
pendant la crise du covid je note
d'ailleurs que les mêmes qui critiquent
le monde d'ambition du budget pour 2023
sont les mêmes réclamés le maintien de
soutien à toutes les entreprises à tout
moment quelle que soit les circonstances
donc je demande un peu de cohérence dans
les positions des uns des autres et je
ne vise pas ici les sénatrices et les
notes qui sont présents mais d'autres
commentaires qui ont pu être fait sur le
budget 2023 c'est un peu commode de dire
au grand public que le budget n'est pas
assez ambitieux sur la du son il pense
publique mais dans ce cas là on ne vient
pas dans le bureau du milieu économie
des finances réclamer des aides
transversales et générales pour toutes
les entreprises
le deuxième élément c'est
poursuivre avec une croissance forte ce
qui suppose de continuer à soutenir la
compétitivité de nos entreprises et la
politique de l'offre c'est ce qui nous a
amené à maintenir la suppression de la
CVAE que nous ferons en deux temps pour
faire preuve d'esprit de responsabilité
4 milliards 2023 4 milliards en 2024
mais où nous proposons d'inscrire la
trajectoire de suppression de la CVAE
dans le budget 2023 de façon à donner
toutes les garanties au chef
d'entreprise notamment industrielles sur
la suppression de la CVL la croissance
est aussi l'innovation nous inscrirons
donc 6 milliards d'euros d'engagement au
titre de France 2030 dans le budget 2023
enfin il n'y a pas de stratégie crédible
de restauration des finances publiques
sans engager les réformes de structure
il faut réduire les dépenses il faut
soutenir la croissance parce que le
plein emploi est encore la meilleure
réponse qui soit aux difficultés de
finance publique de la France mais il
faut également engager des réformes de
structure
l'assurance chômage d'abord dans un pays
où il y a près de 400 000 personnes qui
cherchent les bras de la main d'oeuvre
et qui ne la trouve pas qu'elles sont
mises en poids donc pourvu me paraît
légitime de durcir des règles de
l'assurance chômage c'est ce que nous
allons faire
il me paraît également nécessaire je le
redis de décider une réforme des
retraites qui puisse entrer en vigueur à
l'été 2023 comme le président de la
République l'a indiqué c'est ce qui nous
permettra de financer notre modèle de
protection sociale sans augmenter les
impôts c'est ce qui me permettra de
maintenir la solidarité française sans
augmenter les impôts et de garantir la
prospérité la nation française quand je
regarde aujourd'hui ce qui fait la
différence entre la France et les autres
nations développées la France réussit
partout mais un volume global de travail
insuffisant et là notamment un taux
d'emploi des plus de 55 ans qui est un
des plus faibles des pays développés
près de 20 points de moins que ce qui
existe en Allemagne où il y a plus de
70% des personnes de plus de 55 ans qui
travaillent c'est une perte de
compétences c'est une perte de
savoir-faire c'est une perte
d'expérience c'est une perte de
prospérité pour notre pays il est
nécessaire de mettre en œuvre une
réforme des retraites pour financer la
la vérité française notre modèle de
protection sociale et garantir la
prospérité des générations qui viennent
ce budget enfin marque notre
détermination a poursuivre
l'accélération de la transition
écologique alors je reconnais très
honnêtement que comme nous consacrons
beaucoup de moyens sur le bouclier du
gaz cela a un impact aussi sur la
qualité du budget vert et que nous
pouvons que nous devons faire mieux dans
les mois qui viennent je veux simplement
noter un certain nombre d'avancées
importantes le budget de ma prime rénov
qui passe de 2,5 milliards d'euros et
1,3 milliards d'euros pour le
verdissement du parc automobile et le
1,5 milliards d'euros du fond annoncé
par la première ministre pour
accompagner les collectivités
territoriales dans cette transition
climatique enfin je signale une décision
politique majeure la fin de toute
garantie export pour toutes les énergies
fossiles c'est la première fois que la
France renonce accorder quelques
garanties export que choix un projet
fossile au stade de l'exploration du
raffinage ou du transport je pense que
cela marque un virage très important en
matière de transition climatique enfin
ce budget je le redis reste conforme aux
engagements pris en matière de finance
publique les dépenses de l'État
baiseront de 0,2 % en volume par rapport
à la loi de finance rectificative 2022
avec un objectif avoir une augmentation
des dépenses en volume toute
administration confondu de 0,6 sur la
durée du quinquennat je rappelle que
dans les 10 dernières années passées
c'était au-dessus de 1%
et que dans les 20 dernières années
c'était au dessus de
2%. donc progressivement nous arrivons à
réduire la part de la dépense publique
dans la richesse nationale et nous
ralentissons en volume la dépense
publique on peut là aussi toujours faire
mieux toutes les propositions de
réduction indépendance qui pourront être
faites par les sénatrice et par les
sénateurs seront reçues avec le plus
grand intérêt par le ministère de
l'économie et des finances
merci Monsieur le Ministre la parole est
à Gabriel attaque délégué chargé des
comptes publics
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur général en complément de ce
qui est indiqué à Bruno Le Maire je
dirais que face aux aléas qui sont
devant nous et auxquels nous sommes
confrontés à Léa géopolitique économique
des très difficiles de prévoir ce que
sera l'avenir d'avoir une boule de
cristal en revanche nous avons une
boussole qui est la protection de nos
concitoyens et le budget qu'on présente
est un budget de protection c'est la
protection du pouvoir d'achat avec le
bouclier tarifaire qui a été rappelé par
Bruno Le Maire 16 milliards en net pour
2023 qui vont nous permettre notamment
de maintenir à de contenir à 15% la
hausse de la facture d'électricité et de
gaz sinon ça serait 120 ou 140%. je
pense à la mesure de revalorisation du
barème de l'impôt sur le revenu j'ai
entendu des déclarations qui indiquaient
oui mais ça s'est toujours fait de
manière quasi automatique d'abord il y a
des années où le barème de l'impôt sur
le revenu n'a pas été revalorisé avec
l'inflation donc ça relève toujours d'un
choix du gouvernement et ensuite quand
on est face à une telle inflation la
question peut se poser en l'occurrence
là l'évaluation c'est 6,4 milliards
d'euros lié à cette revalorisation du
barème c'est 6,4 milliards d'euros
d'impôts qui ne seront pas pris au
français alors qu'ils le serait si nous
ne revalorisions pas le barème c'est
important de le noter la protection
c'est évidemment aussi la poursuite de
notre action en faveur de l'emploi on a
le taux de chômage le plus bas depuis 15
ans on veut poursuivre de ce point de
vue là en continuant à investir
notamment pour l'apprentissage et
atteindre le million d'apprentis
conformément à l'objectif fixé par le
président de la République ce qui
explique notamment la hausse très
importante de plus de 6 milliards
d'euros des crédits du ministère du
Travail c'est aussi l'enjeu de la hausse
des crédits du ministère de l'Éducation
nationale puisque la formation ça
démarre très tôt et donc 3 milliards 700
millions d'euros de hausse pour le
ministère de l'Éducation nationale qui
financeront notamment la revalorisation
des salaires des enseignants il y a un
milliard 8 d'impact du point d'indice
près d'un milliard d'euros en plus pour
Reval réaliser les enseignants et donc
tenir l'engagement du président de la
République 10% de hausse pour tout le
monde pas un seul enseignant payé moins
de 2000 euros net par mois à la rentrée
2023 et ensuite on prépare d'autres
étages de revalorisation qui eux seront
conditionnés à des nouvelles missions
pour les enseignants protéger les
Français c'est la poursuite du
réarmement de nos fonctions régaliennes
plus 3 milliards d'euros pour le
ministère de la Défense conformément aux
engagements de la loi d'orientation et
de programmation de la loi de
programmation militaire un milliard 400
millions d'euros en plus pour le
ministère de l'intérieur c'est conforme
à la trajectoire fixée par la loop me et
je citerai aussi le renforcement massif
du budget du ministère de la Justice
plus 8% pour la troisième année
consécutif c'est historique je rappelle
que le budget du ministère de la justice
aura augmenté entre le début et la fin
du quinquennat précédent de 33% et donc
on poursuit l'augmentation massive du
budget du ministère de la Justice
protéger les Français évidemment agir
pour protéger la planète et là-dessus
Bruno Le Maire a rappelé les éléments je
n'y reviens pas et protéger les Français
c'est aussi protéger nos comptes publics
nous sommes passés du quoi qu'il en
coûte ou combien ça coûte 1 € dépensé
doit être un euro raisonné évalué
immédiatement utile à la protection des
Français nous avons fixé dans le cadre
du programme de stabilité on en a des
battues ici cet été une trajectoire de
maîtrise de la dépense publique qui est
la plus ambitieuse depuis 20 ans sur la
durée du quinquennat la dépense de
l'État baissera de 0,4% en volume en
moyenne annuel celle des collectivités
locales de 0,5% des dépenses de santé
continueront à augmenter compris en
volume c'est un choix politique que nous
faisons notamment pour soutenir
l'hôpital et on voit ce matérialiser
cette trajectoire dès le PLF 2023
puisque la part des dépenses publiques
dans le PIB recul on passe de 57,6% à
56,6%. elle atteindra en 2027 53,8%
vous voyez qu'il y a un effort un effort
massif le cœur de notre stratégie de
finance publique reste la création de
valeur et l'emploi l'amélioration du
taux d'emploi comme la rappeler Bruno Le
Maire qui nous permet d'améliorer nos
recettes et de faire baisser un certain
nombre de dépenses de réparation mais il
y a aussi une maîtrise de la progression
des dépenses je terminerai avec un point
de méthode pour dire que ce sont tenus
effectivement les dialogues de Bercy
qu'un certain nombre de sénatrices et de
sénateurs y ont participé je les en
remercie je crois que de la vie générale
ces dialogues ont été utiles
pour transmettre un certain nombre
d'informations en amont de la
présentation des textes financiers au
parlementaires ils ont aussi été utiles
pour le gouvernement puisque nous avons
retenu un certain nombre de propositions
qui ont été émises dans le cadre des
dialogues de Bercy nous avons suspendu
nous l'avons annoncé l'actualisation des
valeurs locatives qui devaient
intervenir l'an prochain puisque
l'ensemble des participants des
dialogues de Bercy nous ont fait état de
remonter extrêmement inquiets sur
l'impact en termes d'augmentation de la
fiscalité sur les commerces de
centre-ville et de baisse de la
fiscalité sur les hypermarchés de
périphérie ce qui est pas totalement le
coeur de notre stratégie puisqu'on veut
au contraire revitaliser les centres
urbains nous avons et je l'ai annoncé
tout à l'heure au Comité des finances
locales pris la décision d'abonder les
dotations de solidarité
urbaines et dotations de solidarité
rurales l'an prochain de 210 millions
d'euros pour pouvoir garantir la
stabilité de la part forfaitaire de la
DGF ce que vous savez que depuis 2017 on
avait sanctuarisé globalement
l'enveloppe de la DGF après les années
de couple sous le quinquennat de
François Hollande mais quand bien nous
avions stabilisé le montant global de
DGF des collectivités locales voyaient
leur DGF BC puisque la revalorisation
des dotations de péréquation se faisait
sur la par forfaitaire sur la dotation
forfaitaire et donc ce que j'ai annoncé
ce matin au CFL c'est que nous allions
abonder l'an prochain des su et des SR
de 210 millions d'euros ce qui veut dire
que pour la première fois l'amendement
des sudsr ne se fera pas sur le dos
entre guillemets de la dotation
forfaitaire mais en plus ce qui veut
dire qu'on garantit à 70% des communes
une des GF qui stable ou en augmentation
l'an prochain ce qui est quand même une
annonce importante qui fait suite aussi
au dialogue de Bercy puisque Christine
pierresbo notamment et d'autres
l'avaient proposé ça sera un amendement
qui viendra le matérialiser vous avez
les parlementaires ont émis des
propositions pour soutenir la forêt et
les communes forestières je me souviens
notamment à Sylvie Vermeillet sur la
question d'escolites nous avons ajouté
une enveloppe d'un million d'euros pour
soutenir les communes forestières en
proie ou scolites nous avons ajouté une
mesure d'incitation fiscale pour
replanter en direction des propriétaires
forestiers nous avons décidé nous
présenterons un amendement puisque ça
n'est pas ce qui était prévu selon la
trajectoire depuis plusieurs années de
sanctuariser les effectifs de l'ONF vous
savez qui ont été réduits ces dernières
années qui devaient encore l'être nous
ajoutons un amendement pour sanctuariser
les effectifs de l'ONF ça fait aussi
suite au dialogue de Bercy il y a eu des
propositions qui ont été faites pour
qu'on améliore l'évaluation de la
qualité de la dépense publique nous
avons ajouté à la loi de programmation
des finances publiques une disposition
qui sera enrichie dans les débats
parlementaires pour établir une liste de
dépenses publiques dont le gouvernement
l'état aura l'obligation d'évaluer la
qualité en débat avec les parlementaires
à l'avenir bref la liste n'est pas
exhaustive mais elle témoigne d'une
chose c'est qu'on a le droit de ne pas
être d'accord surtout c'est même ça en
démocratie mais que ça ne veut pas dire
qu'on ne peut discuter de rien et je
pense que ces dialogues ont été utiles
et j'espère que les dialogues et le
travail que nous aurons dans les
semaines et les mois qui viennent ce
sera tout autant au service de nos
concitoyens
merci monsieur le ministre
je vais donner la parole bien sûr au
rapporteur général mais peut-être vous
savez je dans ce débat budgétaire
j'aurais presque envie de parler de
mineur j'aurais des tas de sujets à
aborder alors Michel collègues soyez
rassuré je le ferai pas mais
je vais quand même en garder une quoi un
petit sujet parce que les dialogues de
Bercy permettent effectivement c'était
je le confirme
utile sur un plan d'abord on a gagné du
temps c'est à dire qu'on est en avance
de phase et le débat déjà budgétaire a
déjà eu lieu avec des échanges certes
avec le bureau de la côte des murs de
commission mais aussi à travers la
presse tout le monde a pu se saisir des
sujets qui étaient sur la table donc
effectivement de ce point de vue là nous
avons gagné du temps
quelques points ont pu être relevés par
vous et trouver des solutions c'est
toujours des bonnes choses mais quand
même sur quelques points essentiels vous
l'avez dit
comment dire on reste sur la copie
d'origine alors il y a un point
particulièrement vous le savez donc
comment dire je vais pas quand même vous
priver de ce plaisir de m'entendre une
nouvelle fois sur la question de la
suppression des impôts de production et
notamment de la CVAE alors je voudrais
il y a plusieurs façons de le traiter je
vais laisser au débat sur les
collectivités locales la question de la
suppression de c.ae et de la façon dont
elle sera remplacée
ou pas autrement en tout cas au niveau
des collectivités locales je vais pas
venir sur ce point à l'instant mais je
voudrais revenir
sur la prévision de croissance d'un mot
que vous évaluez à 1% en 2023 je ne vais
pas la contester personnellement parce
que bon on sait bien qu'il y a des
évaluations très différentes entre -05
et 1 bon mais il me paraît pas une
logique que celui qui mène la politique
économique en tout cas dans notre pays
soit optimiste et donc ils prennent
plutôt le haut de de la fourchette si je
peux dire avec
1%, qu'est-ce qu'on dirait d'un ministre
qui lui-même annoncerait éventuellement
-05 ou des choses comme ça ça aurait
peut-être un caractère presque
auto-réalisateur après donc je crois
qu'il faut toujours que vous d'une
certaine façon quelque
il faut qu'il inspire de la conscience
et de la conscience dans l'avenir donc
je ne le discute pas mais la confiance
ne veut pas dire qu'on ne comment dire
qu'on ne prévoit pas le pire je suis sûr
que vous devez le prévoir or si on fait
0,300 si je peux être imaginaire après
tout c'est jamais que 15 milliards
aujourd'hui chers collègues ça va ça
vient mais 15 milliards de plus qu'il
faut trouver
et donc je trouve je le redis pour la
énième fois je trouve que dans ces
périodes difficiles vous l'avez
d'ailleurs vous-même vous avez introduit
le sujet comme cela c'est une période
économique difficile
dans une période de la croissance n'est
pas assurée même si elle est évidemment
souhaitée et souhaitable et bien se
priver de recettes de l'État n'est pas
une bonne chose alors si c'était Claude
rinal qui le dit je le dis depuis des
années bon
quoi de neuf mais je vois que
[Musique]
le signal n'est plus clair en vous
explique que il y a plus l'effet de choc
quasiment bon donc on baisse ça et moi
j'ai envie de la réponse voyez-vous à
ces braves gens et que si ça sert plus à
rien autant passer à zéro
vous voyez c'est simple et moi je trouve
monsieur le ministre que vous entendriez
leur voix en leur disant
qu'effectivement un choc à 4 milliards
c'est pas un choc et donc c'est zéro
certains économies sur l'ont dit comme
ça alors pas pour qu'ils sont d'accord
avec vous c'est pas mon cas sur l'idée
que la baisse des impôts de production
pourrait être utile aux entreprises etc
mais ils disent renvoyons le à 2027 et
bien au moins ça c'est clair envoyons-le
2027 et si je devais dire autre chose
encore renvoyons également la dernière
phase là des impôts pour les gens qui
ont les plus haut revenus en France
ça fait encore 3 milliards tout ça nous
sauve 11 milliards et si par
extraordinaire il y avait pas une
croissance d'un point mais de zéro mais
voilà on a trouvé les sommes sans avoir
à aller les chercher sur les retraites
où je ne sais où voilà ça me paraît être
une bonne question donc
je l'ai prise et vous m'y répondrez si
vous le voulez bien tout à l'heure et je
passe la parole au rapporteur général
merci monsieur le Président merci
Monsieur les ministres c'est toujours un
plaisir de vous accueillir d'autant que
là on a la chance d'avoir les deux
ministres donc je vous le redis comme
j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire dans le
temps de dialogue des dialogues de Bercy
enfin au Sénat on apprécie
on est bien dans un nouveau quinquennat
et j'y vois d'une certaine manière un
petit changement de méthode moi je vais
je vais revenir sur la question de la
croissance j'ai pas la lecture forcément
je suis pas pessimiste mais j'ai pas
forcément la lecture aussi optimiste que
celle du président
et en fait j'ai une première question
puisque finalement par rapport à
aux économistes
ou globalement on est plutôt autour de
prévisions d'une stagnation
ou d'une croissance plutôt proche de
zéro
qu'est-ce qui justifie finalement votre
optimisme parce que on voit bien que
appartement on est sur le PDF 2023 et la
LPFP ça peut changer par rapport à la
trajectoire sur le quinquennat qui
s'ouvre donc j'aurais besoin de de mieux
comprendre et en tous les cas de cerner
les raisons qui vous ont qui vous
conduisent à cette optimisme dont on
pourrait si malheureusement la
croissance n'était pas aussi favorable
ensuite payé pendant un certain temps le
je dirais le scénario que vous avez
retenu le scénario macroéconomique
deuxième sujet j'entends la volonté de
faire des efforts sur les dépenses
publiques mais le Haut Conseil
d'ailleurs ne s'y trompe pas puisqu'il
constate
en fait en excluant les mesures prises
au regard de la crise sanitaire de la
hausse de l'inflation et de la crise de
l'énergie donc c'est pas rien
que la dépense en volume
d'après vous prévisions croix de 1% sur
l'année qui s'ouvre donc finalement
contrairement à ce que j'ai entendu dans
vos propos moi je plus un pour cent ça
fait pas une baisse
j'ai entendu que ça baisserait à la fin
du quinquennat excusez-moi mais chat
échaudé
là encore besoin que vous nous expliquer
comment il y aurait une forme de
retournement de conjoncture qui vous
amènerait à viser juste sur cette baisse
de la dépense publique donc
personnellement je m'inquiète
c'est même c'est même pas du combien ça
coûte monsieur le ministre je pense
d'abord que ça coûte cher et que le
diagnostic doit être partagé pour
qu'éventuellement le plan d'action du
gouvernement puisse être accepté
troisième sujet sur
qui touche les collectivités locales sur
la loi de programmation des finances
publiques puisque finalement vous vous y
remplacer les dépenses pilotables parce
que par un PDE or qui est pas un plan de
déplacement des entreprises qui est le
périmètre des dépenses de l'État
mais avec un petit problème il inclut
cette fois-ci les prélèvements sur
recettes à destination de l'Union
européenne et au collectivités
territoriales en fait vous renversez les
sabliers la fois précédente dans le
premier quinquennat du président de la
République vous aviez exclu les
collectivités locales et là vous les
remettez dans la trajectoire moi je vous
dis donc je nous alerte et en tous les
cas je vous alerte et vous interroge
qu'est-ce qui vous conduit à vouloir
comme ça contraindre les collectivités
territoriales
vous savez très bien puisque l'un et
l'autre vous avez été sur les bancs
notamment de l'assemblée que les
collectivités locales ont une importance
dans l'investissement public et dans les
règles budgétaires
auxquelles elles doivent répondre et
obéir qui ne sont pas tout à fait les
mêmes que celles de l'État quatrième et
avant dernier point
j'ai entendu parler de la transition
écologique alors je dois vous dire que
j'ai écouté vos propos Alain à l'autre
ont été très bref
et pour tout vous dire il m'inquiète
j'avais l'occasion de vous expliquer
dans les mandats précédents dans les
années dernière que ce que vous
qualifiez de budget vert était plutôt de
la peinture à l'eau ou un vernis
je confirme d'ailleurs que vous avez
besoin de faire venir la nancelle
Valérie Masson Delmotte pour faire
prendre conscience semble-t-il au
gouvernement des enjeux climatiques donc
c'est bien c'est pas parce qu'elle est
l'ancienne que je le dis mais c'est bien
mais je pense que ça ne suffit pas et le
ministre des comptes publics Gabriel
Attal vient de dire on a parlé tout à
l'heure
de l'enjeu écologique je vous le dis
j'ai trouvé que le balayé de ce seul mot
ne suffit pas je pense que on a une
prise de conscience d'une toute autre
ampleur à prendre
parce que ça va concerner
nos sociétés et parce qu'il va falloir y
mettre de l'intelligence et des moyens
et je pense qu'on a déjà perdu beaucoup
beaucoup de temps et que donc il va
falloir vraiment changer de logiciel et
là pour tout vous dire quand je regarde
les crédits de paiement comment tout ça
va fonctionner et puis ce que vous avez
quand même parler d'un fond vert dans
lequel les collectivités locales
seraient associées alors ça je ne peux
que m'en réjouir parce que si on peut
pour une première fois sur ces sujets
articulés le cas le mieux possible et
les actions pour faire en sorte qu'elle
soit productive vous avez finalement le
meilleur contre exemple de ce qui ne va
pas c'est ma prime rénove
un objectif de 80000 pour faire 2000
excusez-moi je le dis comme je le pense
c'est nul
donc évidemment il faut progresser je
pense qu'on va y arriver mais dites nous
peut-être comment vous voyez les choses
enfin dernier élément sur la cbae
les dialogues de Bercy moi j'ai
participé je pense que c'est une bonne
chose il y a quand même je vous le dis à
une espèce de déséquilibre parce qu'on a
du mal à trouver l'équilibre entre la
représentation de toutes les forces
politiques et puis le travail de nos
commissions
dont la raison d'être est quand même de
traiter du sujet donc si pour certains
des nôtres qui n'étaient pas invités
ça met ça met un peu
on a l'impression qu'il y aurait deux
types d'élus voilà je le dis parce que
pour vous comme pour nous c'est pas
toujours le plus agréable quand on est
là bon on est content parce que on a on
passe deux ou trois messages mais je
pense moi qui a une forme de
déséquilibre dans le la prise en compte
des demandes des uns des autres voilà
c'est peut-être pour y réfléchir donc
sur cette cbae moi j'ai j'ai envie de
dire j'ai un problème de là de forme
puisque que ce soit fait en deux ans oui
on l'avait demandé
qui est je dirais la prise en compte de
l'intérêt pour les collectivités
qui ont des compétences de rester
finalement intéressé à l'accueil
d'activités économiques oui mais par
contre vous parlez là encore d'un fond
de ressources on n'a pas un mot à ce
stade sur la gouvernance du fond comment
les élus vont être associés est-ce que
les parlementaires seront aussi dans le
sur le sujet de la des critères de
répartition autant vous dire je
comprends pas la méthode vous allez
proposer de concerter après
avoir finalement une décision qui vient
un peu d'en haut je trouve que c'est sur
le sujet de la richesse de la de
l'activité économique je trouve que vous
êtes à contre emplois c'est me
semble-t-il dans la culture que la
première ministre a proposé qui est une
culture de compromis j'aurais préféré en
terme de méthode que vous élaboriez un
travail en lien avec les collectivités
leur représentants pour ensuite proposer
quelque chose pour lequel ici au
Parlement un accord ou un adouement bien
plus naturellement
quelques réponses au reportage général
éventuellement à moi-même
mais à tous ces murs tout honneur je
vais commencer par le président
et je vais reprendre vos mots
pour commencer par
vos dernières remarques sur le Medef qui
trouve que notre budget manque
d'ambition vous dites que c'est fort de
café
je trouve aussi que c'est fort de café
très bien
je trouve que c'est fort de café quand
on nous reproche de faire la suppression
de la CVE en deux fois alors que nous le
faisons pour tenir compte de la
situation des finances publiques
et que je pense que personne ne peut
remettre en cause la parole du
gouvernement la majorité ou du président
de la République sur la baisse des
impôts nous avions promis la baisse de
l'impôt sur ces sociétés de 33,3 à
25%, c'est fait nous avions promis un
prélèvement forfaitaire unique à 30%
c'est fait nous avions promis de baisser
les impôts de production pour la
première fois depuis 20 ans c'est fait
pour 10 milliards d'euros donc je pense
que personne ne peut douter de notre
détermination à tenir notre ligne c'est
fort aussi de café puisque on nous
demande moins de dépenses publiques
et plus de soutien pour les entreprises
je crois qu'il ne serait pas mauvais de
faire preuve d'un peu de cohérence et
surtout de garder un esprit constructif
un moment où l'économie française est
confrontée à des défis considérables
pour ce qui nous concerne en tout cas
nous tenons notre ligne politique de
l'offre baisse des impôts de production
pour soutenir
l'outil productif français et
rétablissement des comptes publics cela
témoigne au contraire de notre ambition
économique pour le pays
s'agissant de la suppression de la CVA
d'abord pourquoi est-ce que nous le
faisons
on sait pas réveillé un matin en se
disant tiens on va supprimer la CVA
cela fait plus de 5 ans maintenant que
je suis ministre de l'économie et des
finances
et j'ai toujours considéré comme nombre
d'entre vous ici que la reconquête
industrielle était une ardente
obligation
dans un pays qui je le rappelle a
détruit les emplois industriels par
centaines de milliers qui a connu une
hémorragie industrielle comme aucun
autre grand pays industriel en Europe ni
l'Italie ni l'Allemagne donc connu
pareil hémorragien industrielle donc il
y a eu faux économique faute politique
faute collective sur l'industrie
nationale
mais cette reconquête ne peut pas se
faire ni en une année ni par un
claquement de doigts elle demande une
stratégie continue résolue déterminée
constante qui repose sur trois piliers
le premier c'est la baisse des charges
et l'allaègement de la fiscalité sur les
entreprises industrielles alors oui vous
raison nous ne sommes pas forcément
payés de retour Claude Raynal mais cela
nous empêchera pas de tenir cette ligne
là parce que évidemment qu'une
entreprise industrielle j'étais il y a
quelques jours dans la vallée de larves
voir mes amis décolleteurs pour la
cinquième ou la sixième fois vous ne
pouvez pas demander à des industriels
qui sont confrontés à de tel défi de
partir avec le boulet d'un pot de
production 7 fois plus élevé que leurs
voisins allemands
c'est tout simplement impossible
vous ne pouviez pas leur demander de
faire la compétition alors qu'ils
avaient des cotisations patronales
beaucoup plus élevées que celles de leur
grands voisins européens donc nous avons
remédier ces difficultés je rappelle que
c'est cette majorité qui a transformé
les allègements de charge qui était un
crédit d'impôt en allègement définitif
c'est cette majorité qui a engagé la
baisse d'un peu de production c'est
cette majorité qui a fait de la France
au territoire le plus attractif pour les
investissements étrangers c'est le
premier pilier de la reconquête
industrielle c'est pas le plus facile à
faire comprendre parce que à chaque fois
que nous baissons les impôts sous les
entreprises on nous dit cadeau pour les
entreprises non cadeau pour l'industrie
cadeau pour les ouvriers
cadeaux pour la culture industrielle
nationale c'est différent
le deuxième pilier c'est évidemment la
formation la qualification qui passe par
une reconquête culturelle de l'industrie
française
ce n'est pas normal que dans un CFA que
j'ai visité là encore en Haute-Savoie
remarquable qui a 100% d'employabilité à
la sortie
trois offres d'emploi pour chaque gamin
qui travaille dans ce CFA il y a 400
places disponibles il y en a 300 qui
sont pour refus
ça n'est pas normal
c'est la preuve que il y a une
reconquête culturelle à faire sur
l'industrie française pour montrer à nos
enfants et en particulier aux jeunes
femmes parce que le taux de féminisation
est beaucoup trop faible que l'industrie
c'est plus au large
que c'est de la création c'est du
savoir-faire c'est la technologie c'est
des ingénieurs c'est de la valeur
ajoutée c'est des bons salaires c'est
des perspectives de carrière enfin le
troisième combat pour la reconquête
industrielle il passe par la
simplification de la vie des industriels
notamment pour l'installation de
nouveaux sites industriels je ferai des
propositions très concrètes à la
première ministre et au président de la
République dès le début de l'année 2023
sur ce sujet là mon objectif c'est que
la France
retrouve 15% de part de l'industrie dans
la richesse nationale d'ici 15 ans nous
sommes tombés à 10 11%, il y avait
aucune raison pour cela je fixe comme
ambition 15% de part de l'industrie la
richesse nationale d'ici 15 ans avec les
sites industriels les technologies et
les emplois qui vont avec
enfin sur le scénario de croissance ça
me permet de faire la transition avec ce
que disait Jean-François Husson pardon
d'avoir été un peu long sur ce sujet qui
me tient à cœur bien entendu qu'il y a
d'autres scénarios
mais quand on présente un budget on
choisit un scénario central dans les
scénarios les plus sombres de la Banque
de France la Banque de France quand elle
élaborent ces scénarios par du principe
qu'il pourrait y avoir des coupures
d'énergie des délaissages sur les sites
industriels des arrêts de production
massifs à travers le territoire ça n'est
pas notre scénario central et ce que
nous avons fait avec Agnès panière une
hachée avec le plan d'économie d'énergie
le remplissage à 94% des stocks de gaz
la diversification des choses
d'approvisionnement c'est justement pour
ne pas être dans scénario donc je ne les
garde pas totalement d'un revers de la
main bien entendu ce serait très
audacieux de le faire je dis simplement
que notre scénario central reste une
croissance positive en 2023 à hauteur de
1% que par ailleurs au-delà des mesures
que nous avons prises sur l'énergie nous
avons aussi eu à cœur de maintenir la
demande
des ménages français et que lorsque nous
soutenons les ménages lorsque nous les
protégeons contre l'inflation puisque
nous sommes un des seuls pays de la zone
euro où le pouvoir d'achat va continuer
à progresser en 2023 c'est aussi une
manière de soutenir notre croissance
enfin les réserves au départ restent
élevés dans notre pays je pense que
c'est aussi un motif de confiance sur
les collectivités locales je resterai
Gabriel répondent peut-être un mot sur
la transition écologique parce que je
partage totalement votre ambition je
voudrais simplement qu'on ne sous-estime
pas l'ampleur des transformations que
nous avons engagées avec le président de
la République et la Premier ministre sur
la transition écologique tout en ayant
parfaitement conscience qu'il faut aller
plus vite qu'il faut faire mieux qu'il
faut déployer encore plus massivement
nos dispositifs je crois que nous sommes
dans la bonne direction
d'abord nous avons engagé un plan de
sobriété qui sera présenté le 6 octobre
qui est absolument clé et je veux
vraiment bien faire comprendre que les
économies d'énergie que nous allons tous
devoir faire dans les semaines qui
viennent c'est pas pour passer l'hiver
c'est pour passer le siècle
c'est pour nous permettre d'avoir dans
les décennies qui viennent une situation
climatique plus favorable
ne pensons pas que les économies
d'énergie c'est uniquement pour faire
face un problème conjoncturel le
problème est évidemment structurel et
c'est des changements de comportement
complet auquel nous devons être conduits
nous les citoyens les entreprises les
administrations pour réussir à lutter
contre le réchauffement climatique le
fond vert des collectivités locales on
sait pas Isabelle c'est 1,5 milliards
d'euros dont nous pouvons discuter le
déploiement avec vous pour nous assurer
qu'il sera le plus efficace possible
l'accompagnement des ménages sur les
véhicules électriques sur ma prime rénov
c'est aussi des aides budgétaires
massives et je suis prêt une fois encore
c'est un des produits de dialogue de
Bercy qui était très utile à regarder
comment est-ce qu'on passe de rénovation
par geste à des rénovations plus
globales qui ont le sait sont mille fois
plus efficaces pour lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique et
les pertes thermiques enfin deux
éléments complémentaires je rappelle que
France 2030 consacre la majorité de ces
investissements à la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique et les
investissements verts et je veux redire
aussi que la stratégie énergétique
présentée par le Président de la
République à Belfort sobriété
accélération sous énergies renouvelables
et réalisation de six nouveaux EPR est
une manière aussi de garantir la
réduction de notre empreinte carbone
merci Gabriel Attal
oui très rapidement d'abord pour
répondre à Jean-François Husson sur la
question sur la présentation budgétaire
effectivement nous avons une nouvelle
présentation avec un périmètre des
dépenses de l'État on appelle PDE
maintenant qui remplace les deux
définitions qu'on avait avant c'est à
dire la norme pilotable la norme de
dépenses pilotable et l'objectif total
de dépenses de l'État c'est pour plus de
lisibilité c'est pour avoir un périmètre
plus large aussi pour éviter et pour pas
laisser échapper au suivi et au pilotage
des larges pans de la dépense publique y
compris les prélèvements pour l'Europe
et les prélèvements sur recettes en
direction des collectivités locales
c'est le le la maîtrise des dépenses de
la progression des dépenses publiques
demandées aux collectivités locales
n'est pas liée à ce nouveau périmètre
dépense de l'État mais il y est à nos
engagements d'une maîtrise globale de la
progression des dépenses pour tenir nos
objectifs le déficit public donc
vraiment les deux ça fait deux sujets
différents sur la CV
précisément ce qu'on a fait c'est qu'on
a une concertation nourrie avec les
associations d'élus pour définir la
manière dont on penserait la CVAE on a
eu des heures entières de réunion avec
Christophe Béchu Caroline cailleux et
les associations d'élus ces dernières
semaines on les a toutes vues au moins
deux fois et la copie qui est présentée
dans les textes financiers n'est pas
celle qui était la nôtre au départ avant
ces échanges donc précisément pour
répondre à ce que vous disiez sur vous
décidez puis vous concerter non on a
concerté pour décider il y a eu un
certain nombre de bougies j'en note un
majeur qui est le passage d'un
prélèvement sur recettes à une fraction
de TVA c'est vrai qu'au départ on
voulait compenser la CVAE la suppression
de la CVE par un prélèvement sur
recettes auquel on appliquait une
dynamique de 2,5% par an qu'il a
dynamique moyenne de ces VAE des 8
dernières années ça nous semblait être
un gage de visibilité j'ai été pas très
favorable à une fraction de TVA pour une
autre raison d'abord parce que du coup
il y a moins de visibilité puisque la
TVA ces recettes évoluent
de manière moins prévisible qu’a
prélèvement sur recettes l'autre raison
c'est que nous sommes désormais en
majorité relative au capital de la TVA
je parle d'ici ici ici de l'État puisque
avec cette compensation les recettes de
TVA affectées à l'état ce sont désormais
en dessous de 50 % des recettes de TVA
il est essentiel des recettes de TVA
seront désormais affectées aux
organismes de sécurité sociale ou au
collectivité locale ça change pas grand
chose sur le fond si ce n'est que pour
l'avenir pour des majorités qui auraient
apprendre des décisions sur la TVA je
pense que il pourrait y avoir du débat à
ce moment là avec les principaux
bénéficiaires entre guillemets des
recettes de TVA qui diront vous prenez
une décision mais on est aussi
principalement concernés mais on a bougé
sur ce sur ce point là et donc on a
donné la fraction de TVA conformément à
ce que demandait les associations d'élus
ensuite la question c'est comment est-ce
qu'on arrive à territorialiser la
dynamique de
compensation de la CVAE en gros comment
est-ce qu'on permet aux maires au patron
de PCI de pouvoir continuer à dire à ces
administrés on accueille une activité
économique sur le territoire c'est aussi
intéressant pour les recettes de la
collectivité et c'est là où on a
commencé la discussion avec les
associations des lieux avec vous dans le
cadre des dialogues de Bercy ce qu'on a
retenu pour l'instant et dans le texte
c'est de prendre comme critères les
bases de CFE qui sont déjà aujourd'hui
un des critères de territorialisation
des recettes de CVAE plusieurs
associations d'élus et parlementaires
nous ont dit les bases de CFE c'est pas
suffisant il faudrait enrichir les
critères on a dit qu'on était ouvert à
des propositions pour l'instant on en a
pas reçu mais dans les débats
parlementaires je suis sûr qu'il y aura
des propositions sur ce sujet là on est
très ouvert donc pour répondre à votre
question sur la gouvernance du fond etc
moi mon objectif c'est que la
gouvernance du fond est le moins de
décision possible à prendre dès lors
qu'on aurait des critères suffisamment
efficaces pour mesurer l'attractivité
économique des territoires l'affectation
des recettes de CV se fera à partir de
ces critères là
et dernier point pardon sur les
dialogues de Bercy très ouvert à ce
qu'on revoit le périmètre c'est vrai
qu'on a retenu le bureau des groupes des
commissions finances assemblées et Sénat
plus un représentant par groupe en
considérant que le représentant du
groupe communiquerait les informations
assez collègues de son groupe et qu’un
format plus resserré permettait de
fluidifier l'échange enfin si enfin moi
c'est plutôt un bon signe si on me dit
qu'il y a plus de monde qui va y
participer pour les prochaines éditions
et je suis tout à fait prêt à ce qu'on
revoit le périmètre
merci monsieur le ministre nous
démarrons donc les questions je vous
rappelle que nous donnons d'abord la
parole à une un sénateur par groupe sauf
sur le groupe LR contenu de son
importance nous accepterons de voir
Christine lavard des Roger carotc dans
un premier temps merci monsieur le
Président juste pour pour commencer
j'avais oui j'avais pas forcément prévu
d'en parler mais quand j'entends le
ministre le maire j'ai eu l'impression
que les critiques s'adressaient
notamment au groupe les républicains de
se dire vous ne demandez moins de
dépenses publiques mais plus de soutien
aux entreprises je voudrais juste
rappeler que le gouvernement se félicite
des recettes fiscales meilleures que
prévu notamment du fait des rentrées qui
viennent des entreprises donc c'est
pourquoi nous pensons il est qu'il est
utile de les soutenir je ferme cette
première cette parenthèse et juste pour
essayer peut-être de commencer à poser
quelques questions pour essayer de mieux
comprendre alors notamment vraiment le
ministre Attal nous a parlé de la DGF et
j'ai compris que donc la version qu'on a
est déjà obsolète puisqu'il
conviendrajouter des crédits
supplémentaires donc peut-être qu'il
faudrait nous expliquer le mécanisme
parce que effectivement le texte prévoit
bien une augmentation de DSU et de DSR
financé sur l'enveloppe normée donc
c'est il faut comprendre qu'il y a 230
millions qui viennent enfin 210 qui
viennent en plus des crédits déjà
inscrits donc ça c'était la première
question la seconde question concerne
toujours un sujet qui a été
effectivement alors vous dites vous nous
avez entendu dans les dialogues de Bercy
mais peut-être pas assez vite pour que
ça figure dans le texte à savoir la
suppression de la référence des de la
réforme des valeurs locatives
professionnelles donc la question qu'on
a envie de vous poser est-ce juste un
report où allez-vous vraiment revoir
dans le fond la méthode utilisée parce
que le problème est plus tant la méthode
que le report en tant que tel d'un an si
c'est pour refaire la même chose à
l'automne prochain on se heurtera
exactement au même écueil et enfin
revenir sur un sujet qui ne figure pas
aujourd'hui dans le texte modulo une
petite augmentation des crédits mais
c'est le FCTVA en tout cas vous
trouverez le Sénat sur ce sujet que nous
n'avons absolument pas oublier
alors je voudrais aussi revenir c'est
toujours sur les collectivités locales
effectivement sur l'article 16 qui a été
évoqué par le rapporteur général et
celui qui vient encadrer la trajectoire
de dépenses des collectivités alors déjà
pour dire qu'en tant que tel il y a
quand même un grand flou vous
effectivement vous dites qu'il va y
avoir concertation avec les
collectivités vous leur demandez quand
même de présenter ces éléments dans leur
débalimentation des déballementations
budgétaires pour certaines collectivités
le débat dans son budgétaire c'est début
décembre voire plutôt pouvoir voter un
budget avant la fin de l'année donc je
sais pas comment elles vont faire
sachant que aujourd'hui l'article est
quand même assez flou si ce n'est dire
que on a une augmentation limitée à
3,8%, je vous rappelle juste qu'on a
déjà une augmentation de la masse
salariale de 3,5% qui pèse pour toutes
les collectivités pour plus de 50% des
dépenses et que si on prend juste les
dépenses d'inflation sur le volet
énergie alimentation papier qui sont
quand même des charges très importantes
pour les collectivités on est bien de
l'au-delà de 3,8 donc en fait
globalement
[Musique]
[Rires]
je relève juste que les premières
réformes qu'elle voulait être faites
dans l'ancien quéquennat ont toujours
été reportés à des temps meilleurs donc
j'ai envie de vous croire le
différencier elle est tellement
important que ce sera pas très difficile
de faire mieux et sur l'article 7
franchement adaptation du système fiscal
aux exigences de la transition
écologique ou énergétique enfin il faut
regarder le détail parce que c'est enfin
je vois pas en quoi on répond aux
différentes aux différentes exigences
juste par les mesures qui nous sont
proposées je pense que dans les
dialogues de Bercy on a largement parlé
du besoin de faire de la vraie
rénovation énergétique des bâtiments et
je n'ai absolument rien trouvé sur ce
thème là dans l'ensemble des documents
qui nous ont été proposés merci
Christine Roger te rincer une minute
non non non non 30 secondes mais c'est
moi je je vais être beaucoup plus bref
mais je voudrais revenir vraiment à ce
que vous retenez comme taux de
croissance je rappelle que ici même en
2020 en 2021 vous m'avez dit lorsque je
vous disais c'est impossible vous
parviendrez pas vous me répondiez
Cassandre ça n'est pas possible bien sûr
qu'on va les atteindre et on est très
très loin des taux que vous aviez
indiqué en 2020 en 2021 pour les années
suivantes alors bien sûr il y a eu la
crise de la covid bien sûr il y a eu la
guerre en Ukraine bien sûr il y a la
crise de l'énergie bien sûr il y a
l'inflation mais est-ce que tout ça
disparaît en 2023
qui vous a dit que la guerre en Ukraine
allait s'arrêter qui vous dit que la
crise énergétique qui n'est pas que sur
le niveau des prix mais aussi sur la
réorientation le la nouvelle politique
des pays producteurs qui vous dit que
tout cela ne va pas s'accroître
s'approfondir et être finalement
extrêmement difficile à gérer et que
l'inflation ne baissera dans ces
conditions certainement pas en 2023 donc
quand vous dites nous retenons un
chiffre moyen
1% c'est le chiffre moyen par rapport à
quoi parce que tous les autres manques
de France dit 05 au CDE dit 06 et encore
l'OCDE dit 06 mais en fait comme nous
pensons que l'Allemagne rentrera
probablement des pressions en 2023 ça
aura des conséquences pour la France qui
pourrait être ramené à zéro je n'ai vu
aucun organisme dire deux
ce qui vous aurait permis de dire entre
le zéro ou le 05 des uns et le 2 des
autres on a pris un mais là vous avez
pris une vision très optimiste alors
Monsieur Attal nous dit que il y a pas
de boule de cristal il y a une boussole
est-ce que c'est pas une boussole quand
même un petit peu
désorienté parce que on a l'impression
que sous prétexte de politique
volontariste vous êtes franchement dans
un optimisme qui m'inquiète parce que
vous annoncez vous même que la France va
emprunter 270 milliards d'euros vous
dites-vous même que les déficits sont
obamo de 5% 2023 probablement de 6%,
vous créez des posts que je ne conteste
pas sur la sécurité etc mais vous créez
6000 places d'hébergement vous créez
beaucoup de choses et je conteste pas
une politique volontariste mais on voit
pas en parallèle de réduction de
dépenses le parvenir là-dessus mais de
fait beaucoup de dépenses volontaristes
dans un environnement extrêmement
difficile alors que
le président de la République nous avait
annoncé lui-même un budget de guerre un
budget de crise et on a l'impression
d'avoir un budget classique très
optimiste et probablement inatteignable
merci monsieur le Président je reviens
pas sur la question sur les super
profits Eric Bocquel la poser mais c'est
en effet une question absolument au
centre du débat politique donc c'est
important qu'on vous interroge aussi sur
cette question messieurs les ministres
d'autant que Monsieur le Ministre
Lemaire ça ne rentre pas dans les impôts
de production
et la proposition qui est faite
aujourd'hui est une proposition
temporaire et non pas une proposition
d'une taxation pérenne donc je pense que
même si nous ne partageons pas la
politique la philosophie politique du
gouvernement
c'est une proposition d'équilibre à un
moment très particulier de l'histoire
qui ne remet pas en cause l'ensemble de
votre politique moi j'avais deux
questions l'une sur comment s'inscrit
l'éventuelle réforme des retraites dans
la loi de programmation des finances
publiques parce que il a compris que
que cette réformée lieu ou pas dans le
courant de l'année 2023 vous considérez
sûrement à juste titre qu'elle n'a pas
d'impact sur la réalisation budgétaire
en 2023 mais ça en a forcément sur la
loi de programmation des finances
publiques d'ailleurs vous le dites dans
votre introduction mais dans le texte
lui-même la phrase est à la fois très
courte et très civiline la possibilité
de notre trajectoire reposera notamment
sur les réformes structurelles engagées
je sais pas d'ailleurs si la réforme des
retraites rentre dans les réformes
structurelles engagées ou non ça demande
quand même un peu plus de
précisions de détails et certainement
de chiffres ensuite sur les questions
des collectivités locales
on a parlé de la CVAE de la CFE de la
difficulté aussi à trouver des
dispositifs pour compenser la perte de
ces recettes pour les collectivités
locales et aussi des besoins de tenir
compte des dynamiques territoriales
est-ce que vous êtes prêts même si ça
n'est pas dans le budget actuellement
mais à regarder aussi comment retrouver
ses dynamiques sur d'autres sujets alors
il y a une question qui tiennent qui
peuvent par ailleurs abonder l'objectif
de politique du logement taxe sur les
logements vacants taxes sur les
résidences secondaires même si une taxe
sur les logements vacances c'est l'État
qui la perçoit mais de revoir ce
dispositif et deuxièmement est-ce que ça
compte beaucoup du coup pour beaucoup de
communes notamment celle où je suis élu
à Paris à revoir les limitations qui
sont aujourd'hui imposées à la taxe de
séjour et qui n'est pas un pot qui
repose sur
les contribuables français
particulièrement mais justement sur le
tourisme qui est aussi dans notre pays
beaucoup du tourisme international
ce qui évitera certainement d'ailleurs à
beaucoup de collectivités locales de
devoir augmenter la taxe foncière ce que
vous êtes prêt à redonner des marges de
manœuvre sur différents modes
d'imposition aux collectivités locales
merci Rémi daniel broyier Merci
Président Monsieur les ministres
collègues
en introduction de vos propos monsieur
le ministre vous avez évoqué les
incertitudes très fortes qui pèse au
plan énergétique au plan de l'inflation
je veux rajouter même si vous y êtes
venu à la fin de votre propos
l'accélération gravissime de la crise
climatique que nous traversons l'été la
illustré pour tous ceux qui pourraient
encore en douter à travers les
sécheresses les incendies ou les
événements majeurs mais ça n'est pas un
problème national c'est un problème
international le Pakistan montre les
enjeux géostratégiques que cette crise
climatique fait peser sur le devenir sur
les migrations sur la vivabilité même
des villes et des territoires c'est la
raison pour laquelle ma première
remarque sera pour vous dire que les
propositions que vous nous faites même
si les mots annoncent des inflexions
très loin du compte et puisque on est
dans les combien ça coûte moi je
voudrais vous dire combien ça coûtera de
ne pas nous mettre à la bonne hauteur je
vais illustrer par quelques chiffres
premier chiffre en gros il va y avoir il
y a eu 40 milliards il va y avoir 36
milliards ou 16 milliards net de
boucliers énergétiques il va y avoir 2
milliards et demi sur l'isolation des
bâtiments mais si on veut quitter notre
dépendance au gaz russe et ne pas tomber
dans la dépendance au gaz de schiste il
faut mettre un facteur 10 sur cette
engagement il faut plutôt mettre un
minima 10 milliards sur l'isolation
thermique il faut mettre aussi des
crédits sur la place du rail on n'est
pas du tout dans les ordres de grandeur
qui permettent de bouleverser il y a
tout un autre volet qui n'est d'ailleurs
pas toujours un volet coûteux sur la
sobriété qui est annoncée mais qui
mérite pas des mesurettes mais vraiment
un engagement
objectifs pour une sobriété heureuse
donc il y a sur ces sujets la nécessité
de dégager des moyens d'action alors
supprimer la CV VAE
de notre point de vue ça n'est vraiment
pas le moment c'est un désarmement de la
capacité de l'État à agir dans ce
domaine comme dans le domaine de la
justice sociale donc nous nous sommes en
désaccord mais si vous maintenez cette
volonté que vous avez réaffirmé
rencontre après rencontre à minima
messieurs les ministres proposaient des
conditionnalités climatiques ou sociales
ou ceux des salaires en ce qui lorsqu'il
s'agit d'entreprises qui vont bénéficier
d'une réduction des impôts ou
engagements climatique chiffrées pour
ces mêmes entreprises et pareillement
pour l'État toutes les mesures que nous
prenons devraient être mesurées à l'aune
de leur impact sur la crise climatique
ou sur la justice sociale il y a comme
ça des niches fiscales qui méritent
d'être regardées je l'ai révoquerai pas
ici on vous fera des propositions
il y a notre proposition évidemment je
redis ce qu'on dit mes collègues sur la
question de la taxation sur les super
profits avec un petit regret monsieur
adminis le maire que vous n'ayez pas lu
ou apprécié à sa juste valeur ce qui a
été déposé par les groupes de gauche et
écologiste qui définit très correctement
ce qu'est cette taxation et qui n'en
fait pas une taxation pérenne comme ça
vient d'être dit par mon voisin mais
nous proposons aussi un ISF climatique
parce qu'il faut aider les gens les plus
aisés ceux qui dépense le plus et
émettent le plus d'émissions de CO2 à
réduire ses émissions et l'ISF peut
avoir un impact très positif si les
conditionné à des enjeux climatiques
dernier point sur les collectivités
territoriales le fond vert d'un milliard
et demi n'est clairement pas la hauteur
non plus or les collectivités
territoriales seront sans nul doute
c'est notre conviction le premier
facteur de la transition écologique du
pays et dans une République
décentralisée je crois que nous devrions
prendre au moins autant soin des
collectivités territoriales que vous le
faites des entreprises et soutenir leur
capacité à agir tant dans la cohésion
sociale que dans cette transition
écologique voilà sur tous ces facteurs
nous vous ferons des propositions et je
termine quand même sur une question les
collectivités ce qui a dit mon collègue
Boquet la commune dont j'étais mère à 2
millions d'augmentation de ces frais
d'énergie j'ai visité avec le président
du SEDAL du Sénat l'Institut Gustave
Roussy voilà quelques jours 5 millions
de hausses des frais d'énergie pour un
hôpital mais où aller chercher cette
augmentation du coût de l'énergie
lorsqu'on est un hôpital il y a là un
sujet je rajoute les universités qui ont
par ailleurs souvent des locaux
un bouclier tarifaire pour les
collectivités sur l'énergie pour les
collectivités les hôpitaux les
universités merci Daniel
donner la parole à Jean-Claude requier
puis à Pascal Savoldelli oui merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre
des efforts fournis en faveur certaines
catégories sociales le président a dit
que pas payé de retour
je suis pas sûr que de faire des efforts
pour l'éducation vous ayez le mode des
enseignants qui peuvent faire des
efforts pour l'écologie que vous avez le
droit des écologistes mais ça c'est un
autre débat on n'est pas là pour gagner
les catégories sociales mais on est là
pour essayer de gérer un pays et de
résoudre l'ancien problème alors ce
budget nous n'ont pas encore étudié dans
le groupe mais il y a beaucoup de
dépenses c'est vrai ils ont été dit
d'ores et dépenses assez peu de
d'économies mais je comprends que la
situation est difficile et qu'il faisait
soutenir
l'économie qui est en difficulté alors
quelques interrogations simplement
certaines ont été posées en particulier
sur le crédit un peu recherche ça a été
fait donc un petit mot sur le prix de
relance qui vont se terminent en 2023
quelle est la proportion des crédits
engagés consommés actuel et a-t-on une
évaluation de leur efficacité de la
question c'est pour l'Ukraine on a voté
les crédits en pdfr pour l'Ukraine on va
invoquer sûrement PLF et à ton idée de
l'évaluation de du montant troisième
question la ciao la suppression d'un
CVAE il y aura-t-il une compensation
pour le département et est-ce que ce
sera proposé comme ça a été fait pour le
RSA pour les départements en pff puis
après je dirais que ce PLF est
relativement court puis je crois que
mais est-ce que est-ce qu'on peut
s'attendre dans des modifications au
cours de l'examen parlementaire nous le
verrons
merci Jean-Claude alors Pascal ça vole
des lits puis Bernard delcro
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
les ministres avant de porter une
impression sur seulement deux sujets
on est dans une situation inédite
puisque on a une forte hypothèse de 49-3
l'Assemblée nationale non parce que
pouvoir aussi impression de parler dans
une bulle mais les dialogues se font
quand même avec une épée de Damoclès
et quand on a les lits de l'opposition
et ne croyez pas en moi de faire la
victime mais 49-3 à l'Assemblée
nationale et un budget de droite annoncé
ça fait droite + droite + droite donc
les offres de dialogue à l'opposition il
faut après les démontrer donc il faut
nous dire et moi aujourd'hui comme la
première fois où j'ai été au dialogue de
Bercy et je ne suis pas retourné je ne
vois aucune proposition faite aux
oppositions parlementaires concrètes
donc faut un langage de vérité et dans
le langage de vérité je vous avoue une
seule satisfaction et là je vous accorde
sur le maire franchement c'est honnête
c'était bien de nous dire dès le départ
qui avait pas 45 milliards pour le
bouclier tarifaire
il était temps et vous avez eu
l'honnêteté de dire que c'est seulement
16 milliards donc c'est 10 c'est fait
dont acte et ça s'apprécie mais après il
y a un sujet là je vous avoue tout à
l'heure j'ai attendu mon tour avec
beaucoup d'apaisement mais quand je vous
vois parler de la même manière des
entreprises que des collectivités
territoriales en prenant les mêmes
critères des 2 millions de chiffre
d'affaires ou de moins de 10 salariés là
je me dis que c'est un virage politique
que vous prenez c'est la première fois
et s'il est plus anciens diront si je me
trompe si utilise la même critérisation
pour les collectivités territoriales que
pour les entreprises c'est la première
fois que j'entends ça
avec toutes les conséquences que ça va
avoir pour les collectivités
territoriales alors on peut me dire
l'Europe tout ça je vois bien les
négociations et je vous encourage à
gagner mais il y a un moment si on peut
le faire pour ces collectivités
territoriales il faut le faire pour les
autres vous nous annoncez 420 millions
d'euros les a déjà voté c'est les plats
réchauffés on les a votés même nous
l'opposition les a voté
donc c'est un plat réchauffé donc il y a
rien de neuf de ce côté-là donc moi je
vous pose la question est-ce que vous
allez avoir la volonté politique de
revenir à la tarification réglementée de
la vente de l'énergie
pour les collectivités territoriales et
les entreprises demandeuses voilà une
bonne fois pour toutes et alors
évidemment venir mais comment et ben il
faut indexer au prix de production des
indexées du prix du marché de la
spéculation voilà ça c'est une
proposition alors elle est peut-être
d'opposition mais au moins c'est une
proposition responsable la deuxième
chose et jean-philis parce que ça a pas
été traité par le président rénal
celle-là était et personne n'y a répondu
la question de la tranche des revenus
il a raison moi je vous fais tout de
suite une économie au moins de 3
milliards vous allez faire un cadeau
fiscal à 905000 foyers qui touchent plus
de 100.000 euros de revenus fiscal par
tranche
vous moi si vous me demandez et c'est là
que l'opposition elle peut être entre
guillemets constructive si vous me dites
que les premières tranches il fallait
revaloriser je vous dis oui et vous avez
raison et dans ces cas-là je vote pour
donc c'est pas de l'obstination mais
expliquez-moi en quoi les 905000 foyers
qui ont des revenus fiscaux de référence
par tranche de plus de 100000 il faut
leur accorder la même rovalorisation
enfin franchement je vous le dis avec un
peu de véhémence mais c'est quoi pour
cela plus la taxe d'habitation l'année
prochaine plus l'ardevance
d'audiovisuelle et là on leur fait
encore un cadeau non franchement je vous
dis ça je pense pas que un peu emporter
je m'en excuse mais correct dans mes
propos ce que je vais vous dire c'est
que c'est ça qui gronde aussi dans la
société et ça c'est pas seulement une
affaire que de gauche et droite c'est
une partie de l'arrêt d'une révolte
intériorisée donc je vous le dis dans le
cadre des débats qui sont les notes et
merci de votre attention d'abord
peut-être un principe
quand nous avons étudié le PLF
à l'été je suis arrivé au débat et j'ai
indiqué que nous entrions avec 22
milliards d'euros de dépenses
supplémentaires et que nous devions
sortir avec 22 milliards d'euros de
dépenses supplémentaires moi je fixe le
même principe pour le PLF nous entrons
avec 5% de déficit nous sortirons et 5%
de déficit public
et je veux redire à quel point la France
est à l'euro près
alors j'entends bien les remarques sur
les collectivités locales sur les
services publics sur d'autres personnes
qui souhaitent davantage protégées sur
un bouclier pour les entreprises mais
pardon tout cela n'est pas à la portée
de la France c'est aussi simple que cela
donc il faut faire des choix ici on me
trouve des économies je dis pas des
taxes ou des impôts supplémentaires
parce que ça c'est la solution de
facilité à chaque fois j'y reviendrai
très bien mais quand on me dit il faut
indexer la DGS sur l'inflation où il
faut un bouclier tarifaire pour toutes
les entreprises je dis simplement que ce
n'est pas à la portée de notre bourse
et que nous devons te dire des 5% de
déficits publics
et que dans le fond il y a des
entreprises qui sont exposées la
concurrence internationale elles
arrivent plus à vendre évidemment quand
vous allez chez les décollecteurs de la
vallée de l'art et qu'ils vendent des
pièces de véhicules automobiles et qui
doivent les vendre en Asie en leur dit
en Asie mais il y a pas de flambée des
prix il y a aucune raison qu'on paye
plus cher aux pièces cela il faut les
protéger
mais d'autres commerçants qui sont
restaurateurs par exemple
ils peuvent faire passer une partie de
la hausse dans leur prix de vente
et donc je ne rétablirai pas des mesures
de quoi qu'il en coûte parce que ce
serait dispendieux pour les finances
publiques et que cela ne ferait
qu'alimenter un peu plus l'inflation
dans les mois qui viennent
et même chose pour les collectivités
locales bien sûr qu'il y a des communes
des communes qui sont en grande
difficulté il faut les aider
puis il y en a d'autres qui sont moins
en difficulté puis il y en a d'autres
qui ont pas forcément fait de bons choix
de gestion au cours des deux ou trois
dernières années ce qui est juste traité
tout le monde la même manière je suis
pas certain
et je suis pas certain que nos
compatriotes approuveraient cela donc il
faut regarder de près et soutenir ceux
qui en ont besoin mais tenir cet
objectif 5% de déficit en 2023 et
d'ailleurs vous l'avez parfaitement
rappelé parce que vous connaissez les
sujets parfaitement en tenant les 5% de
déficit en 2023 nous ne sommes pas les
bons élèves de la zone euro
nous ne faisons que respecter la
trajectoire qui nous permettra de tenir
les 3% de déficit en 2027 ce qui fait je
le rappelle l'un des derniers États de
la zone euro à repasser sous les 3% de
déficit public
donc oui je serai un traitable sur ce
sujet parce qu'il envoie la crédibilité
de la France la crédibilité de nos
finances publiques et qui n'a aucune
raison que la France accuse des déficits
plus importants que celle de ces autres
grands voisins européens voilà pour le
principe ensuite sur les questions qui
m'ont été posées sur la croissance j'ai
pas grand chose à ajouter à ce que j'ai
dit bien sûr que l'environnement est
particulièrement instable et incertain
ce que je constate simplement portant de
fait c'est que en 2021 la reprise a été
plus forte que ce que nous avions
anticipé ce que je constate c'est que
parmi les grandes économies de la zone
euro Italie Espagne Allemagne le premier
pays à avoir retrouvé son niveau
d'activité économique d'avancer c'est la
France
parce que sa politique de relance a été
rapide efficace et puissante
ce que je constate aussi c'est que les
prévisionnistes disaient que nous ne
pourrions pas dépasser 2,3% de
croissance en 2022 relisez tout ce qui a
été dit
nous allons faire deux,7 et croyez moi
je suis tout aussi surpris par la
vigueur de la demande par la figure de
l'activité touristique le retour de
l'activité de service dans notre pays
qui est très puissante et tant mieux
donc le pire n'est pas certain il faut
certainement s'y préparer mais il n'est
pas certain et je crois que mon rôle de
ministre de l'économie était
parfaitement rappelé par le président
rénal c'est non pas de faire de la
prophétie auto-réalisatrice mais au
contraire de pousser le pays vers le
meilleur et vers ce qu'il peut accomplir
c'est-à-dire je pense 1% de croissance
en 2023
sur la CVL bon je veux dire monsieur
Laignel dont j'ai lu les déclarations
que je trouve un peu révoltante par les
cadeaux Medef
et je trouve pas que ce soit des propos
acceptables ni digne
amis des finances ne prend pas des
mesures pour faire plaisir à qui que ce
soit
un organisation syndicale ou une
organisation patronale il le fait parce
qu'il estime que c'est bon pour le pays
nous ne prononcons cette décision parce
que nous estimons en conscience que nous
ne ferons pas de reconquête industrielle
avec des impôts de production cette fois
plus élevés que ceux de nos voisins et
que c'est maintenant que ça se joue
qu'il est urgence à le faire parce que
les marchés ils doivent être pris
maintenant que la reconquête
industrielle doit se faire maintenant et
que si nous n'avions pas baissé les
impôts de production de 10 milliards
d'euros je pense que jamais global fin
de Reese n'aurait investi chez ses
micros à Grenoble
et que la France aujourd'hui ne serait
pas une des nations qui va pouvoir
maîtriser les technologies de
semi-conducteur y compris dans les
gravures les plus fines
donc je n'accepte pas que qui que ce
soit aille parler de cadeaux aux Medef
quand nous voulons d'abord nous battre
pour la reconquête industrielle on peut
comme vous le faites très bien ici
discuter des procédés échanger contester
les approches que nous prenons mais pas
de stigmatisation de cette sorte qui me
paraissent maladroite inappropriée et
injuste sur le bouclier tarifaire pour
répondre aux questions qui m'ont été
posées sur ce sujet c'est un enjeu
majeur c'est la plus grande dépense
publique de 2023 nouvelle dépense c'est
45 milliards d'euros que nous mettons
sur la table
c'est ce que ça va nous coûter c'est ce
que nous mettons pour protéger nos
compatriotes
y compris les entreprises
il va falloir qu'on penser parce que
quand on dit ma séquence de hausse je
rappelle que le marché c'est 100% donc
si vous voulez qu'on fournisse de
l'électricité qu'au fond des gaz il faut
bien compenser les producteurs qui
perdent c'est comme ça que ça se passe
une réalité économique qui a marché et
nous ne sommes pas tout seul au monde
donc si on veut avoir du gaz et
revêtricité il faut le payer auprès du
marché sinon vous n'en avez pas c'est la
pénurie et c'est la chute économique ça
coûte 45 milliards d'euros
peut-être plus si les chiffres
augmentent et si les prix augmentent
peut-être un peu moins si les prix
baissent à partir de là nous avons des
recettes 19 milliards d'euros qui
viennent des énergies renouvelables j'y
reviendrai c'est la question à la
taxation qui est une question tout à
fait digne politiquement importante ou
chacun a ses opinions à chacun ses
convictions elles sont toutes
respectables mais là nous récupérons 19
milliards d'euros de recettes des
énergies renouvelables sur les
énergéticiens à qui on a dit lorsque le
prix est bas on vous rembourse vous
faites des investissements sur le
renouvelable sur l'éolien sur le soleil
donc ça vous coûte cher ça vous rapporte
pas beaucoup on vous compense on a
compensé pendant des années à hauteur de
milliards d'euros
quand le prix de l'énergie est supérieur
à ce prix garanti pas désolé c'est nous
qui récupérons l'argent
il s'agit très favorable parce que c'est
une rente et qu'il n'y a aucune raison
qu'il y ait des rendent notre pays ça a
rapporté 8 milliards en 2022 ça
rapportera 19 milliards d'euros en 2023
là dessus vous retranchez encore 9
milliards d'euros de TICE que nous ne
prélèverons pas cela vous amène à 17
milliards d'euros
vous retirez un milliard d'euros de
recettes qui viennent de l'énergie
hydraulique il n'était pas concerné
jusqu'à présent vous arrivez à 16
milliards d'euros de coûts
mais ce que dépense l'État en brut ce
qu'il met sur la table ce qu'il met dans
la poche des Français 45 milliards
d'euros
donc personne ne peut dire nous pas
massivement mais nous réduisons la note
grâce à ce système de marché qui
d'ailleurs a été adopté par l'Union
européenne
ensuite sur je regrette que Monsieur
Salbris soit parti ce que je voulais lui
répondre sur les tranches d'impôt sur le
revenu avec le même enthousiasme que le
chien il a eu des propos modérés et
enthousiaste j'aurais aussi des propos
modérés enthousiastes je rappelle juste
que ceux qui travaillent en aura le bol
de payer toujours plus d'impôts ils en
ont assez et je pense que la coupe est
pleine pour eux il redoute une grande
sociale et bien moi je redoute une
gronde de tous ceux qui travaillent et
qui en ont assez travaillé pour le droit
de police et qui trouve qu'on leur prend
trop alors me dire mais c'est étrange
les plus élevées enfin je rappelle que
notre pays 10% des contribuables payent
70% de l'impôt sur le revenu donc si
vous voulez leur expliquer que quand il
y a de l'inflation on leur pique leur
argent je pense que vous préparez des
jours difficiles avec les classes
moyennes
je rappelle que dans notre pays quand on
parle de révolution d'agitation sociale
souvent ce sont les classes moyennes qui
ont refusé que on leur prenne trop et
qu'on ne respecte pas leur travail et
qu'on ne respecte pas leur engagement au
service du pays donc oui je maintiens
qu'avoir indexé le barème de l'impôt sur
le revenu sur l'inflation c'est
simplement protégé ce qui travaille et
que c'est une décision juste pour les
classes moyennes
enfin sur la question la taxation c'est
pas une question anodine parce que nos
compatriotes légitimement disent ben
nous on va être bien contribution
les collectivités vont être mis à
contribution l'État va être bien
contribution c'est normal que les
entreprises qui font des bénéfices liés
uniquement à la flambée des prix paye
ils ont raison
ils ont dit aucun doute là-dessus je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec ça la
preuve que j'en récupère 19 milliards
l'année prochaine c'est quand même pas
rien bien sûr qu'il faut que les
entreprises qui font des rentes payent
elles payent et elle paieront soit par
le mécanisme de marché que je viens
d'indiquer soit on contribuant
directement quant total fait une remise
de 20 centimes d'euros à la pompe ça va
directement la poche des Français ça
coûte un demi milliards d'euros à Total
quand c'est ma CGM baisse le prix de ces
containers ça va directement dans la
poche des PME quand les banques
s'engagent à plafonner à 2%
l'augmentation des tarifs bancaires ça
va directement dans la poche des
compatriotes et quand il s'engage à
réduire des frais bancaires pour les
plus modestes de 3 euros par mois à 1
euro par mois là aussi il participe et
c'est très bien donc bien sûr que nous
voulons que l'argent des rentes aille
dans la poche des Français et nous le
faisons à hauteur de plusieurs milliards
d'euros ce qui aucune ambiguïté
là-dessus en revanche je veux redire que
derrière ce terme très séduisant
de taxation exceptionnelle sur les super
profits se cache en réalité une taxation
permanente sur tous les profits de
toutes les entreprises de CAC 40 et
d'ailleurs certains d'entre vous l'ont
dit comme à l'Assemblée nationale de
manière très claire moi j'ai regardé la
proposition de la nups attentivement
bien entendu c'est bon c'est mon travail
de regarder des propositions des
oppositions qu'est-ce que j'ai vu la
nups propose de taxer toute entreprise
dans le résultat fiscal 2023 serait
supérieure de 25% à la moyenne des
résultats 2017 2019 il y a 5 ans donc ça
veut dire que toute entreprise
dont les profits ont augmenté de 25% sur
5 ans ce qui peut arriver pour beaucoup
d'entreprises sera taxées autrement dit
dès que vous faites des profits vous
êtes taxés autrement dit dès que vous
réussissez vous êtes taxés bien c'est
contre cette maladie française que je me
bats depuis des années parce qu'on
commence par taxer soi-disant les plus
grandes entreprises et on finit par
taxer le profit de toutes les
entreprises sans exception PME comprise
donc ça n'est pas une taxation chez
Super profits c'est une taxation sur les
profits tout court enfin on me dit c'est
exceptionnel ah non c'est pas
exceptionnel puisque vous proposez que
cela dure jusqu'en 2025
c'est pas exceptionnel du tout c'est
permanent et puis bon courage à la
majorité de 2025 qui voudra revenir
ensuite sur cette taxation c'est comme
la taxation exceptionnelle sur les
salaires elle a été mise en place en
2009 ou 2010 c'est de l'exceptionnel qui
dure en général en France en matière de
taxation est toujours en place
donc c'est bien pour cela aussi que je
dis que ce n'est pas la bonne solution
que je préfère la solution européenne
qui prévoit que uniquement pour les
énergéticiens et pas pour toutes les
entreprises uniquement sur 2022 on est
un prélèvement qui soit de 20% lorsque
le résultat de 20% supérieur à celui de
2019 2021 et pas 2017 sur le résultat de
2022 une fois encore pour un seul
secteur sur la période de temps la plus
proche et pour la seule année 2022 ça ça
me paraît un dispositif beaucoup plus
raisonnable vous le voyez c'est un débat
qui mérite d'être poussé jusqu'au bout
pour chacun dévoile la réalité de ses
ambitions et la réalité de ses
intentions en matière de fiscalité
[Musique]